[Musique]
le département organisée ce samedi 1er
juillet à l'espace red line journée de
rencontre d'échangé d'informations pour
les étudiants en mobilité
c'est une journée qui rentre dans un
cadre global d'accompagnement fait du
département notamment sur les prix
mobile donc avant et pour leur permettre
de finaliser leur projet ont réuni sur
un même site l'ensemble des partenaires
pour qu'ils puissent avoir en fait
l'ensemble des réponses sur un même site
à des questions soient spécifiques soit
globale donc on a des ateliers qui
fonctionnent soit de façon collective
soit de façon individuelle
un gain de temps dans la recherche
d'information grâce aux neuf partenaires
réunis sur le même site
parmi eux le département la région la
dom le crous l'université de la réunion
mais aussi la lmde la maif la mae et
vittavi le département un dispositif qui
s'appelle net bosse donc l'aps d'être
beau site une plate forme d'inscription
en ligne aux aides du département
ça concerne tous les étudiants ceux qui
sont à l'affût en mobilité ou ici à la
réunion
donc pour ceux qui partent en mobilité
donc ils s'inscrivent sur cette
plateforme numérique net boss et puis ça
permet d'accéder à deux dispositifs
concernant la mobilité donc la bourse
départementale
par ailleurs nous avons un deuxième
dispositif qui est la location de
scolarité nous on vient on à
lien en accompagnement donc des
étudiants qui sont inscrits à
l'université de la réunion et qui
souhaitent partir dans le cadre d'un
programme des changes dans une
université partenaire dans différents
programmes d'études
près de 600 parents et étudiants ainsi
pu trouver des réponses à toutes leurs
questions
mon projet moi c'est de partir en master
1 de droit en double cursus avec un
master en management à paris en présence
sur site je suis venu
or et c'est là en plus de renseignements
sur les aides qui sont mises à
disposition par les différentes
collectivités à l'égard des étudiants
qui veulent partir en mobilité plus près
même ceux qui veulent poursuivre leurs
études ici mon fils il va partir à faire
ses études en métropole plus précisément
à bordeaux je pense que c'est une très
bonne initiative de
de retrouver mon intime ses partenaires
sur le même lieu ça nous plaît de de
faire en une seule demi journées de
rencontres étonnantes donc c'est
intéressant kono le département de la
réunion souhaite bonne chance à tous ses
étudiants qui s'envoleront très
prochainement vers de nouvelles
destinations
[Musique]